just a guitar bass and drums on the new
album the devil strikes again heavy
metal band rage prove that a trio can
still make a big racket the title song
is a reference to the group's past
the song itself is basically very much
related to sent by the devil from the
Black and White Album we had this kind
of thresher elements i was in which was
this energy is very important for this
music
rage performing at the buck in the open
air festival their power metal has
captivated fans for more than three
decades in spite of its often dark
lyrics I wouldn't really say that the
lyrics that i write a completely
negative or so when you read carefully
and read between the last lines there's
always a very hopeful perspective behind
it in the positive side alive in the
band came together in North
rhine-westphalia in 1984 back then they
called themselves a danger and had a
rather different look as ser on the
first year we marched into rehearsals
dressed from head to toe in rivets and
leather we banged our heads while
playing acted like fans to be friends at
five
why don't you love
in the early 1990s rage finally got
their big international break much to
their surprise they were even big in
Japan financing ember 1992 we did our
first tour in Japan and had no idea what
to expect we didn't know we were teeny
stars there got a harder through that
first show we came out on stage in place
was full of little girls screaming like
for the Backstreet Boys collection be
when they said boys
rageous lineup has changed frequently
over the years the last two people came
in early 2015 due to personal and
musical differences but frontman Peter
PV vagner wanted to carry on there's not
really a possibility to save your lineup
so i decided to win new musicians for
the belly just a year later rage
returned with a new guitarist a new
drummer and new songs
marcos rodriguez and basilius money at
apollos may be new but partners known
them for years I was grew up with his
missus band and they really understand
the ridge spirit now I realized that
really perfect players for this passion
so everything will develop really good
for me rage have crashed out 22 albums
over the last three decades if all goes
well the group's latest incarnation will
churn out a few more
you